hey guys welcome to the Evan and Kaitlyn
podcast the podcast now five times
improved by new technology such as a new
desk a new camera anyone that's
listening can't really hear this right
now remotely with the remote everything
is new everything is is like we just
took apart so today we released our new
podcast desk video which is what Evan is
showing off with his fancy camcorder
zoom and we had to take apart everything
and put it back together oh please don't
you want guys like gonna just leave it
right here let's go all the way in let's
go farther let's let's go all the way
I'm sorry for anyone who's just
listening to this it's just in my eyes
it's just one eye now it's pretty
impressive this is this is an upgrade so
much because I mean we got our very
first camcorder just to like experiment
like hey let's experiment with a video
aspect to this let's stream with it
let's do all of that well and the reason
we do at camcorder instead of just
normal camera is because you can plug it
into power and it won't die it'll just
record indefinitely yeah and it has a
nice full size HDMI out it's really
exciting speaking of updates and news
things and etcetera etcetera main thing
I know I should actually probably start
with outline first so in this podcast
we're gonna kind of do like a little
news update
something something will be added and
post right there that lead just right so
we're gonna go through some updates and
then we have a sit-down chat with Bob
from I like to make stuff and then we're
gonna go to the thing of the week I'm
not sure if we're gonna be able to fit
all that plus a game into this one but
the games aren't going away it'll be in
total about half an hour of us chatting
in about half an hour of interview we're
speaking of updates we already covered
the wonderful upgrade that is our new
video camera and eventually it's just
going to keep on getting a better I
really like just upgrading our life up
getting our content upgrading all of
that stuff I will admit though I
struggled with a new camera
because our the new camcorder it's
expensive twice as much as our regular
video camera and so it features well
yeah the features but I mean there's
features this features for everything
but it but it was kind of a struggle
because it was like you know the podcast
and streaming which is what we're using
the camcorder for we should talk about
the garage streaming in a bit too yeah
yeah that's one of the big big things
write that down yeah like those are
still kind of newer things the podcast
and streaming whereas like we're not
we're not really making much money on
this $20 $30 thank you but it did feel
kind of weird spending twice as much on
this camera then we spent on our main
video camera investment in the long term
no no I do agree with that and I guess
also like things just jump up in price
pretty quickly to make it worth getting
a new thing like if you if like we had
$200 camcorder and as I original and if
we wanted to get like the next more
expensive version there just wouldn't be
that many improvements it wouldn't be
worth it wouldn't like the first
improvement so there's a $200 then it
goes to $800 for like mid level but then
when you're at the mid level you kind of
wanted to just go up one more feature
one more piece
more quality of scope creep but it's
like I also don't want to get like a
medium level camera and then we have to
update again that almost seems more
wasteful and yeah but now when we're
doing live streaming from the garage
we're gonna have two cameras like our
main main camera and then like the
secondary camera for the other
perspective we probably will use this
for filming for really long scenes cuz
like oh man behind the scenes stuff for
this podcast desk video we didn't record
like the entire second poor it was bad
well like we only got footage of it
because we were streaming and we had bad
super crappy camcorder quality footage
yeah well we we we started recording and
then the camera just died and we were so
frantic with everything else the the I
mean you you saw a little bit of a panic
if you watched our live streaming desk
build yeah yeah well I was thinking like
live streaming desk this is I misspoke I
misspoke yeah yeah but this desk is
really great it's really gonna upgrade
our our streaming and that's you know a
decent chunk of our content that we're
gonna make moving forward not they were
reducing anything else but if we're
making one YouTube video per week in one
podcast per week in one podcast per week
and maybe at least one or two live
streams a week the amount of minutes
coming from this camera is greater than
the amount of minutes on YouTube you
know yeah but also it's like this
content takes so much less time to craft
[Music]
but it's not as editing I mean every
week we're producing like a piece of art
or a functional furniture or renovating
a door or a house or a room it's like
the scope of that like what we're
accomplishing is so much greater - yeah
it's hard to do in a week sometimes it
is very hard to do in a week sometimes
we've been thinking about like trying to
I'm
we always say we shouldn't over ask
ourselves but we're we're actually like
talking about ways to put that into
motion moving forward and then recover
some of that in our talk with Bob I
think another thing that I wanted to
copy cover somewhere because we don't
really have a place to cover this but it
seems relevant because it's very present
in our mind so we just wanted to share
with you guys and this seemed like the
best place not belaboring my transition
there but we want to talk about
copyright strikes for a little bit my
gosh so we thought that we are so much
safe because we were smaller so if you
guys haven't heard about it there's been
a lot of drama about it if you watch any
of the like YouTube news going on but
it's basically the YouTube copyright
system someone can put a copyright claim
on your video basically claiming that
they own the rights to the music in your
video or some piece of content and you
in your video and then them having the
claim on it means that they get any
money from the monetization of it well
they can pause monetization or I mean
it's crazy they have control over the
monetization of it basically and if your
video gets a copy strike on it you can
write back to like appeal it but it's
almost on the person who claims it is so
it's like if we wanted to claim someone
someone else's video let's say that half
of someone else's video was our video
with them like voicing over it and it
wasn't used in a fair use way or
anything like that whatever we could say
hey you used our video and you owe us
money for it and then if they said no
we're using it fairly we can just say
nope you are the same thing is if their
video has nothing to do with us we could
put a claim on it we could claim it a
video and they could say I know that
your videos not in this at all and we'd
be like too bad we'd say it is and the
only way to get that removed is to take
us to court because youtube doesn't want
to step in and be the arbiter of these
decisions it wants which makes sense I
mean it does make sense like a legal
little thing but the the issue is
there's no punishment currently and
apparently there's talks of like a
punishment being put in place but
currently there's no punishment to
people making false claims here and they
are and everywhere so yeah people are
just doing it like crazy so that's kind
of like the background of copies yeah
so we we have gotten a few copyright
strikes in the past for music that we
have used that we had their license to
and we're like hey we have this license
here's our proof and no big deal it
eventually goes away not that fast at
times but it eventually goes away but we
kind of got our first like erroneous
copyright strike you know such a crazy
story to me that we just had to share it
but we also had to give you the
background so this copyright claim
there's that there's a musician that we
really like yeah DJ quads who we use a
lot of his music in our videos like if
you hear any of the music that kind of
sounds like old-school big-band but then
like hip hop beats thrown into it also
that's DJ quad and a lot of youtubers
use this music it's pretty popular yeah
they use them he puts his music out
there like for people on YouTube which
is so cool it's so cool we're so
thankful for him and we've even
supported some content creators like
this via patreon in the past when
they're putting out music yeah I think
he didn't have them yeah but so anyways
there's this channel that basically took
that song and some poorly over it didn't
remix it didn't do anything and just
sang
literally over a DJ quad song and then
they put a copyright claim on our video
that included the DJ quad song yeah yeah
and it was slightly more convoluted than
that they must have sublicense out their
songs to another bigger channel to
patrol and and do copyright which is
also weird there's a channel that had
like 200 something thousand subscribers
it was they had music videos and stuff
and they're the ones that put the strike
on us for someone else's videos that
wasn't on their channel so it's like we
got copy struck for using the song that
we had permission to use by a company
who got permission to copyright strike
other people from another channel whose
the original artist song and put their
Bab singing over it it's like it's so
convoluted and it was so infuriating to
us was it last night
ya know two nights ago when we liked the
email popped up like like instant vent
fest with the page what's happening it's
a crazy crazy world out there yeah I
mean so luckily like we responded saying
you know there we know who the original
artist is like here's a link to their
work they here's a link to where they
say they put up their music for free to
people to use the person claiming this
does not own the song like we will reach
out to the original artist if needed but
we're very diligent about this I'm sure
that if these people are spamming these
like copyright strikes to all sorts of
people which it seems like they are then
some people won't notice that the email
some people may not find it
some people oh thank you may not catch
it or I don't know I don't know yeah I
can definitely see people getting away
with it cuz otherwise why would they do
it hmm
luckily they'd like we appealed it and
they took down the claim otherwise we
were like do we take to Twitter do we
sue them yes I'm ready we are ready to
fight this yeah cuz like the the main
way we've seen people fight it is like
they go to Twitter and they tweet about
it and until YouTube sees it but that's
like I think some people have sued I
think some people maybe have sued but
that's that's a lot of money that's
costly that's potentially more money
then you know we'd be losing it to the
Oh certainly - dealing 100% would lose a
lot of money I was really stressed about
it because there's just been so many
stories where people don't back down
even if you provide proof and I was like
oh my gosh it's gonna happen to us and I
was ready to like campaign for this and
fight this like they're not they're not
like a big channel they're not I'm not
sure how much they're abusing it but I
was like no I
this is something that's worth fighting
and not an aldready
I was fired up but thankfully they're
back down yes they did back down which I
was very relieved but I mean one thing
we kind of touched on a little bit ago
with the streaming you talked about
Garage streaming and that's something
that we're also gonna be starting soon
which is really exciting yeah we
streamed our resin pour for the rainbow
desk yeah and this is so much fun
because talking to you guys live and
it's so much easier for me to like I
don't know react and share things with
you guys cuz
yeah Kayla and I are on the same page
she knows what's going on I know what's
going on we've both been involved in
this process in this design for days or
weeks and I think so usually because I'm
the one keeping your you're the one
keeping track of like project next step
and I'm keeping track of video next step
so usually I'm the one that's like in my
head I'll be like oh man we've been in
the zone and we haven't actually camera
like we should say something to the
camera and like sometimes I have to kind
of prompt you yeah um so that's not just
me talking but I feel like since we are
streaming it you were very chatty
although sometimes too chatty yeah
sometimes too chatty and also I'll chat
directly to the chat that's all on my
phone footage just like staring at his
phone like answering questions but you
know and just like broken sentences cuz
it's like it'll just be like the answer
not reading the question than seeing the
answer we're learning we're what we're
learning I mean we didn't really like
yeah but we're excited to do stuff like
that in the future when we're doing more
resin pours or when we're doing work
that's conducive to it like leather
working or quiet quiet work just know
does not power tools not like basically
not woodworking because all like all of
the woodworking we do is power tools
unless we somehow miraculously learned
how to use hand tools and have the
patience to do that which is like not
likely I mean we still got to get this
video out in a week I think if we're
putting something
it'd be like one month yeah yeah that's
not what we want to do yeah but I think
that that uh we should we should
introduce Bob before we go into the
interview okay so most of you guys a lot
of you guys probably know who Bob is if
you're involved in them there's only one
Bob by the way there's oh yeah there's
only one Bob he doesn't need a last name
but if you are involved in the maker
community on YouTube you know who he is
Bob I like to make stuff um awesome
Channel all of our first inspirations we
talked about him I believe in Episode
one when we were talking about our
inspirations for this channel because he
just does so many different things like
he doesn't limit the type of project he
tackles which was that like I've said
the word inspiration like three times
really in the past two seconds but it
was a big inspiration for us to know so
great to vary what we did I'm not sure
if he knows this so much but he was
almost kind of like a mentor to us too
he liked games our very first shoutout
he was our first job my first shoutout
like it was um we we I don't remember
which video we had just recently put out
but I remember we woke up and we had
like way more comments than normal
subscribers I'm like what's happening
and we were still really little we were
in fear like did someone mention the
making a podcast there are people saying
yeah Bob sent me Bob sent me like heard
about you guys on making it and we
hadn't listened to the most recent
episode yet so we like when to go listen
to it we were really excited so we even
recorded creepy we've told him that's
history okay so I guess we did
[Laughter]
yeah it was really exciting it was like
our first boost I remember when he
mentioned us in the podcast we were at
like 300 something subscribers yeah and
he's like I don't even know how I found
them but I found this channel yeah it
was great was kind of crazy it was the
first time that like it was just like
our first big sharing of our Channel it
was very validating to you know know
that we were somewhat on the right path
and that yeah things were going okay and
everything yeah yeah cuz it's very much
like you kind of feel like you're
creating in a vacuum a little bit when
you first start putting out videos cuz
there's just not very many people
watching them you know you have to
really fight for those views in the
beginning got a fire singing so accurate
so yes so good and then we uh we met him
for the first time at Bay Area Maker
Faire New York Maker Faire okay cool
yeah cuz it was at the matter hackers
like 3d printing thing beforehand oh
yeah like the pre-party thing yeah yeah
those are our first time hanging out and
we've we've been to like I'm pretty sure
every event we've been to he's been to
in every event he's been to we've been
to ever feels like that so we always get
to hang out together at the you know
various events which is really cool and
we actually got to do a collaboration
which was so fun yeah so we'll have both
of our collaboration videos linked below
if you haven't seen those but also we
kind of said you should know who Bob is
but we didn't tell you what type of
videos he makes he makes videos around a
lot of the things that we tackle he kind
of moves from video to video topic from
3d printing to woodworking to
metalworking to Arduino to like he
doesn't like cool like props and stuff
like you yeah working on an r2d2 yeah I
want to see his r2d2 video I wonder how
much he's gonna get into it it's a long
term project
long term anyways we we
into the interview with the objective of
talking about the future of like YouTube
and educational content and where he
plans on going and shifts in YouTube in
general and it ended up basically being
a like therapy session you know I think
that we might title this episode
something like therapy session with bob
coggan yeah we definitely kind of went
off the rails it was really good talk we
did start off talking a little bit about
like the future of YouTube and where we
see things going but then we also talked
about like some algorithm theories and
Bob challenged us to find our purpose
I'm not sure if we found it yet yeah you
can you can hear our thought process as
we try to think it through and I think
he meant to be like alright guys think
about your purpose not like I think
implied us not now but later in the
future
and although as I'm Kate and I are off
on tangents just yeah thinking about it
right there let's jump into instead of
doing like typical background things
because I'm sure you've probably been
asked the same background questions a
few times maybe tell us about how you
got started with your channel what's
your favorite video really hard I
couldn't do that nor of all videos
what's your favorite YouTube video of
all YouTube videos I haven't watched
that why milk video by Taven biller
I actually have one okay what's that
video but it's like this little girl
reading a kids book and she's narrating
what all the kittens are so yeah she's
like you know a picture of a big cat a
little cat and she goes she points the
little one and she goes or the big one
she goes I'm here mom twice the little
one No
but she's so serious about it too that's
great well I think that what we're gonna
try to do is like tackle different
subjects not that we need to stick to
them in any way interview but I think
that one thing that's really interesting
to us obviously doing content creation
is the future it's it's very unknown but
you've been in this content creation
game for one of the longest a while and
I'm not sure I'm sure you've seen a lot
of the changes as they've been in
progress and we're curious to kind of
get some of your thoughts on like where
you see it going in the future and like
in general for like the whole community
and also just curious to get your
thoughts for you and your channel and
because I you have a strategy we we know
even if we couldn't tell just knowing
you yeah yeah I do yeah well I mean I
think I don't really know where it's
going because I don't think any of us
know where it's going because they don't
think like even the creators or the
audience or the brands or anybody
involved nobody really knows where it's
going yeah because it's changing all the
time based on all those variables right
so the audience has a huge amount to do
with what is created how it's created
how its presented the creators are the
driving creative force behind that and
then the brand's inform who is has the
resource to do what for the most part
yeah so you've got all these variables
feeding into this thing so nobody can
predict the future from any of those
three points of view well there's an
algorithm affecting cities - yeah I mean
like one shift we've seen a lot is more
and more a longer form content on
YouTube I mean when you were first
starting out there wasn't much long-form
content it's like from what we could
tell video right like yeah I was like a
death sentence like I remember at some
point thinking like this thing is
getting too close to 10 minutes like I
gotta cut it down Wow and now people are
like got to get it over 10 minutes so
yeah my videos if if I have a like we
had a twenty seven minute video I think
last year the longest one we've ever
done
we are the best performing videos in
recent history ma'am
and that's bizarre to me I still don't
understand that but it's good to know
that that's not something you have to
worry about so much I don't know that
you should try to make them longer yeah
but you know it's not a we got to get it
under this time when you think it's part
like part audience and part you know the
algorithm that's our personal guest
because more and more people I mean just
looking at us as examples we watch
YouTube videos with our meals now you
know or apps are breaks we sit down and
that's our thing instead of TV right you
know and more people we talk to that's
what people are doing like you know we
talked to our younger cousins and they
don't watch TV at all all they watch our
YouTube for their TV show replacements
right and that's that's a big chef you
doing that then it's a lot better videos
like 15 minutes 20 minutes because they
actually sit down and watch something
you don't have to find something else
yeah and also with YouTube somewhat
prioritizing watch time if they watch to
10 minutes or to two minute videos or
127 minute video YouTube kind of likes
that 27 minute video a little bit more
perhaps yeah it's not like we can see
within their black box in any way yeah
but there's guesses well yeah I mean
their algorithm is a black box of black
boxes yeah you need to be really clear
about that but you don't know what it's
doing
yeah but they I think that they are
putting in the inputs that they want to
prioritize for and they let it run and
do its thing and see what optimizes
those outcomes the most it's kind of
I've actually had some conversation with
specific engineers and the in the
algorithm yes it's not like a team it's
not as people yeah it's a huge ordeal
that nobody touches all of it yeah
multiple people it's probably on purpose
absolutely part of it but they don't
necessarily really feed it like this
factor is important and we're like deep
in the weeds yeah no we love it this is
not and this factor you know X is not
actually important they don't say that
they say like how can we provide the
most applicable content for user a ah
that's what we care about and then what
does it take to get them stuff that
they're gonna want to
watch repeatedly and so it's a the
system figures out how to provide stuff
to people and it's so it's not like
length doesn't have anything to do with
it ah it's if Evan likes long videos
then we try to get him long videos uh
I'm like short videos it tries to get
you short videos so it's not interesting
it's not as like straightforward as you
think it's really based on the users
watch habits I'm saying this like I know
I'm going this is all secondhand yeah
and whatever maybe it is more about like
changing and more and more people are
using my theory it's a really catchy
name it's called you are the algorithm
you got the audience is the algorithm
because the algorithm is absolutely
completely per the person yeah that's
going on yeah and and also and this is
my guest too but my guess is that
viewers as they interact with videos
they're ranking it's for people like
them so like google has a profile for
each person if I react one way to video
if I react very positively they might
recommend that to another person like me
mm-hmm
yeah so yeah I think back to like your
original question of you know where's
this going yeah I don't know I don't
think anybody knows but I do think that
one of the best ways to manage that is
to that that unknown is to be flexible
yeah that's something we always try to
do is not to be super rigid and how
things are done or how long things are
or that any of that yeah I've got a core
set of values the thing I want to hit
yeah the execution needs to be fluid it
has to be able to change with whatever
is currently expected or yes by sponsors
or by audience or whatever yeah don't
let that stuff move around a little bit
so so you had your it seems like you had
your core set of values from pretty
early on yeah in your channel I feel
like we've kind of been figuring it out
like we never it's not something we kind
of like formalized in our heads and
we've I mean we jump around project
types of a lot of course as to you but I
feel like we've also jumped around a lot
in terms of like the purpose
Epis of our videos like is it is it a
tutorial or is it just like
entertainment or is it somewhere in
between yeah and yeah I don't really
have a question have a challenge for you
though right because I think that is one
of the most important things that you
could do and I say this in a way not to
be negative to anybody else I think one
of the biggest problems with channels in
our space is that people don't have that
thing figured out yeah what if you don't
have that thing figured out then you
have nothing to make your decisions
against you have nothing to get sponsors
against you have nothing to vet like is
this video meeting the standard that I
wanted and if you have that one sentence
or one paragraph one page description in
your head as to this is the standard
decisions for business are so much
easier yeah through that and like if it
works it works if it doesn't it doesn't
do you have a rough one I have a rough
one let's not hold us to this record
this permanently okay to inspire people
[Music]
you're out as you can see I just went to
inspire people and show that making is
fun and that they're capable of doing
more than they might think but like the
main thing that I think we want to show
is you know it's tough the main there's
our to them there's an inward yeah and
then downward is what we have a trouble
with the inward I think we know then
what I think we know and it's like we
basically want you know something we can
do that is creative we get to do it
together and we have fun and get to
spend time together
and it's sustainable and something
sustainable that you know something
we're gonna do for a few years and burn
out on so we're working on that part
yeah I think we're getting closer and
closer to that internal goal I think so
I think the hard thing is like so like
the heck that might be incompatible with
external because as we've shifted
towards the the videos that we have a
lot more fun with don't do well it's
known when we were doing just more
always you know strictly project base
and it was more about the project it was
more consistent it's easy to provide
value when it's just like here is this
value right here here's how to prepare
drywall that's value instant you know
yeah yeah but I mean I think you know
coming up with that decision in that
whatever that thing is like you can look
at that from a bunch of different
perspectives so you can get really
granular like I want to provide
informational like a list of these are
the things you have to do to do X or you
can back out a layer and say like I want
people do know how to do stuff they
don't know how to do or you can go out
even further I want people to experience
something they never experienced so good
one yeah we just need real broad but
real broad yeah the broadness has
flexibility to it yeah but it also
becomes a little less useful in the
vetting process so yeah there's a medium
in there right yeah that is a sweet spot
that will be good for all of the things
you need it to do I think
yeah I have those words that don't make
a sentence in my head what are your
words
okay that's fine fun is this for the
external for the external okay fun is it
it's a big part of it I think and that's
that's what we didn't know at first when
we were first starting this we knew we
wanted to have fun but we didn't know
that like communicating that fine that's
a big part of the video I think more and
more as we've made our videos we've
found out to be part of our identity and
I think that's a bigger revelation than
we thought so fun is an important one
inspirational I think would be one that
we want cuz like making is really fun
and I think that that that's a unique
perspective that we can bring and then
show people the fun but also show people
to fail it's like bring in reality too
well so fun inspirational and I don't
have much after that little bit yeah but
I mean even that's a start like you know
if you're looking at a sponsor you can
like still those are two filters that
you can put a sponsor through yeah
maybe that's not the end thing that you
end up with all the time but that's it
that's a start on yeah that's true we do
kind of do that unconsciously cuz
sometimes you know a sponsor will come
to us and they they want us to use a
specific product and a specific way and
we're like that sounds like a really
boring video so let's pass right it's
would be boring yeah it might be you
know a very practical video it might be
like very fun for other people that
aren't us but like for us specifically
it would be boring so yeah right one
thing that was really interesting to me
and I don't know why like maybe this
wasn't as big of a mind-blowing moment
because you've been living it but like
do you remember the video when you
clarified there's Bob at I like to make
stuff first Bob and I like to make stuff
I click aside for those who might not
understand the Bob app I like to make
some first Bob and I like to make stuff
theory so to be every video bob says hey
I'm Bob make stuff - you're gonna make
this I don't even know which one you
said I said exactly da no you can't tell
all right let's go back into I've never
clarified it in a video moon in the
comments you clarified it in the comment
and I think it was like whoa
and we were like what I forget who have
us found it and we were like did you
know actually tax team at and team hands
one yeah it's really need a good on that
have people people totally just heard
one thing yeah
stuck with it's kind of like yeah me
verse Laurel you're leading the trend
that was a thing I like went over before
the very first video like I was like
what's the intro gonna be I wanted to be
a consistent whatever I do now I'm gonna
do from now on man I want to set this up
that was that was hyper intentional yeah
and it's worked out to where now it
makes sense it didn't make sense for
several years and that that's been a big
change I mean you guys have are up to
four and a half yeah yeah that's awesome
it's crazy is really really crazy to me
yeah but it's fantastic and like I'm not
sure like if this is the appropriate
place to talk about it but it seems like
you have a vision are you gonna share
that at some point in a more like direct
way or you just kind of let gonna let
that be revealed on your channel over
time um I'll probably just like let it
kind of be revealed yeah because it also
is kind of fluid you know like this I
don't know what the future is like I
mean I have a goal I have a I don't even
know the right word for it I have a
skeleton that all this is working on
yeah yeah and I don't think that has to
be revealed to people for them yeah for
it to happen so yeah I would rather kind
of keep that close to my chest
like I've always said one of the things
I like about the way I do things is that
people don't know what to expect week to
week to week right that's that's you
their expectation is that they don't
know what to expect right so yeah I
would like to keep that going in every
way that I can but that that is a plan
forward I mean that is that that's
that's a great strategy I mean we know
like you know I mean I think you
mentioned it before too but when you get
the comments of like
I love that I don't know what this is
gonna be about and I'm watching it
anyway and it's awesome you know yeah
yeah but I think that that that ties
into part of our strategy that we're
still forming for the external looking
goals is like exposing people to things
that they may not have thought they
might be passionate about you know it's
like you know exposing you know metal
workers to epoxy you know like who knows
those two could completely mix you know
and and that's exciting to us so um yeah
so so do you have like is your statement
on your website or something or is that
something that you share no but it's all
it's all internal we have written on a
whiteboard in the office there's a
there's a book have you ever read story
brand told us about it
damn it maybe one of us talked about it
but I think there's a few books like
that that I think are really good about
helping you realize how important it can
be to have a one-liner in your head
there's maybe not transparent to
everybody else who do need to be but it
gives you that kind of heading that
you're working on yeah and I was
listening to that book on a run one time
and I already had this idea in my head
but there was something in that book
that gave me the one line to describe it
wow I'm not gonna say to the office I
said to Josh I just said that line and
he was like oh got it
I know exactly what you mean that's our
thing yeah the fact that he knew exactly
what I was talking about without the
context of the book and without the on
it I'm like all right that that tells me
that we're actually on to it yeah okay
so when Anthony came on I said alright
here's our guiding principle yeah this
is the line yeah got it
boom that's really cool that's powerful
yeah it's cool we need to get on there I
think that uh when we were hanging out
with Bill and bit from punished props
they brought up like the mission
statement and how that has really helped
them find themselves and judge their
content and judge their projects you
know who channel who's been doing this
for a long time and yeah yeah and
expanding their team and yeah and I
think having that vision wall to expand
is really great and I think partially
for us part of
problem is when we first got into this
we didn't fully know where we wanted to
end up I think you had a pretty strong
vision but for us our main goal was just
like to work together to work and and
you know figuring out this journey from
the instructional to the come along with
us and like be on this journey with us
that's been a big process and there's
been a lot of revelations along the way
where we're like I feel like every like
few months we are like oh my gosh now
like okay I feel like I understand our
channel so much more like now this is
how we're gonna add three main phases
quick aside just so y'all know we
actually talked about the different
phases that we can see our channel has
gone through in the very first episode
of the podcast so we'll link to that
okay back to it but it's been it's
definitely a journey and I think that
makes sense I mean not having a plan is
sometimes a good plan but like having a
guiding principle let's do that you're
like like oh I got a I got a plan to
have time to plan and I'm like we've
been fully converted to air table now we
have everything for the next six months
in there by the way air table is a piece
of software that Bob introduced us to
and we use it to organize everything our
projects companies we work with contacts
deliverables and voices hung out with us
and at an event Evan is probably pulled
out his phone to show it's really nice
all right well I hope that makes sense
film factory excellent all done
good to go planning turns out a little
tip for you you can copy and paste
entire lists into air table which I
don't know why I never realized that oh
thank you list on your phone yeah well
like any list so I have been putting in
days for my schedule like manually and I
was like minute it's kind of a pain to
put these in and I real
you can go on google search for the
dates for every Thursday for the rest of
the year and it gives you a list and you
copy and you just paste him in a table
and it populates the entire year Wow one
thing they were like when you said that
you're gonna have a plan breaks yeah we
were like we we have to plan breaks oh
we definitely plan breaks we have a
planned break coming up and I'm not sure
how much we're gonna stick to it I was
listening to the podcast about vacations
they're not gonna they're not gonna do
that vacation unless you plan it right
now put it on the schedule I think that
one of the big chef's for us is this
this this this level of we're not like
they're you know like we have kind of
arrived to the point where we're full
time and we're not like stressing about
money and lining everything up anymore
by the same time that's still a
tentative thing for us yeah so far yeah
it's hard to kind of trust in it mm you
know I mean after five years six years
something like that something like that
like I feel like is it more liable like
morale I mean I'm not I don't stress
about it surviving
yeah anymore mm-hmm in fact I'm just
kind of blown away at how much I'm not
stressed about surviving but I do still
feel the there's always work to be done
no matter how hard I work there's always
the next month there's always the next
thing I think it's super unhealthy for
all of us yeah I was like somebody a
little while ago about that about how
you know for us we were talking about
coming up after work to the dinner table
with our families and how we can't turn
our brains off and how hard that is and
how bad that is for everybody involved
and the thing that I found that's made
that a little bit easier is getting
ahead which is totally obvious and
easier to say than do yeah but I've
found that by being a little bit ahead I
can walk up the stairs after work and be
like I can leave that downstairs be
brown we don't have anything for next
week
can't I can't put it down I can't let go
of that and so I was telling him that I
think one of the best things that we can
do is just try to get a lead or let go
of the schedule which is one of those
really controversial like maybe you
should do that maybe you shouldn't I
don't know I think Levengood the stood
in your comfort level and your longevity
within the career is way more important
than a schedule and yeah any any of the
other stuff you know that's true I think
letting go of the schedule would be a
really nice thing but the main problem
is sponsors you know 60% of our incoming
sponsors and you you kind of have to
have a schedule to line them up with
yeah you know and and that's but there
again that goes back to having having
the thing to vet against yeah
part of that description can be your
your internal part you know can be about
like how much time do we want to have to
live life outside of this yeah yeah and
let's take on the appropriate amount of
sponsors to make that happen I think the
biggest conclusion that we've got is the
only way we can slow down is by doing
like sometimes last videos which is hard
yeah even when you do smaller projects
there's still everything that goes along
with it yeah and you go through all of
that everything I know it's like going
back to what you're saying earlier like
you know walking up to dinner and not
being able to turn it off for better for
worse like because we're both doing it
don't turn off
yeah there's no incentive to turn off
yeah yeah you know and I'm like you know
recently uh like Evans brother and his
family started YouTube channel so now
even when we're with family that used to
be we were turn it off and now
strategizes like pull even more of our
family so like we've we've gotten to a
point where we can consistently keep
about a week's lead and we still are
working way too much but it's crazy the
amount of stress reduction even though
we're working the same amount of hours
like we're not working any less just cuz
we have the lead
um but it's so much more enjoyable just
weirdoes happier
yeah we're just happier and everything
we do yeah and when you know if we go to
an event like this or whatever it is and
we eat up some of that lead that's when
we notice that our stress levels jump
and it's just so much it is that even
that's the same amount of work every day
yeah yeah so we did all these
renovations recently we did two
back-to-back and then we did another one
that's not out yet that's kind of like a
big project and so you're just working
non-stop for like three months like way
more than I normally work in then when
we finished those the next week we got
two and a half project videos done in a
week and then and since then another
week or so we've had another one and a
half done and we were sitting around in
the office the three of us at the end of
the day for like an hour just chatting
and I looked at Josh and I'm like I kind
of feel bad like we should be doing
something right now and it felt weird to
just be okay and to be ahead I was like
I don't think that's good you should be
okay if you actually have time yeah and
there's that internal like stress
pressure anxiety something that you have
to be working all the time even if you
don't need to work all the time and I
think that's just the thing that we all
have that is not good for us like even
if even if you're five videos ahead
there's something you know what what if
something happens in the near future and
then I eat at my lead and I could have
had that sixth video yeah you know but I
think another thing that I try to keep
in mind is I I saw this to-do list
organizational chart this way to make
decisions about what to do and there is
important not important urgent and
non-urgent and the things they get all
of the attention are the important and
urgent and then oftentimes next is that
important but not urgent like what you
tend to do is you lean towards the
urgent but not important when you should
be focusing on the important and not
urgent yeah and sometimes like you kind
of need a little bit that lead all over
that breathing room to focus on
important but not urgent things such as
decide
the future of your company brainstorming
the the projects that will lead to a lot
of growth or a lot of personal meaning
or whatever it is and you just don't
have that time if you don't stop right
and and that's like the urgent no that's
important but not urgent that's getting
ignored and sealer I'm actually in a
couple of weeks I'm planning to take a
weekend somewhere I don't know where
like get a cabin or something by myself
with no computer a notebook in my phone
and like just go and because I have this
huge list of stuff in my head that I
don't think about because I don't think
I have time to think about yeah and I'm
gonna go with intentionally with that
weekend to get all that important stuff
yeah just focus on that not be
distracted by anything else and it's
weird that I'm both really looking
forward to that and also really dreading
the fact that I'm gonna have to go sit
somewhere and actually parse all the
stuff that I haven't parsed you planned
your planning I did we sometimes do that
we did we just kind of have to leave the
house get away from our phones or
computers and we just go for a walk yeah
we do that like imagine what Chuck's
yeah and I'm sure you do get a little a
small bit of that wall running or yeah
while running do you just try to like
escape completely a lot of times I'll
escape thanks yeah yeah we just don't we
need to get some working out and that's
like that's that means like the level of
like when we can put aside time to work
out again that's when we're starting to
like turn the curve of like I think that
one thing that's interesting another
mind ship that we've gone through
recently is we realize whenever we say
we don't have time what we're saying is
it's not a high enough priority yeah
yeah I mean we obviously have time for
things if we make time for it yeah and
what do you make time for the priorities
and we just got to reach if the
priorities I guess yeah I've tried
honestly and this may be just semantics
I've tried for several years now not to
say that I'm busy because I think yeah
that's just like a I just don't think
that's a good thing to say about
yourself yeah I tried to look at it more
like I am
using what I do every moment of every
day because I'm an adult and I'm only
choosing the things and I'm filling up
with my time with the stuff that I care
about and the things I think matter and
that doesn't mean I'm busy that doesn't
mean people are forcing me to do stuff
all the time and I don't have any free
time I've just filled my time up yeah
intentionally yeah yeah and so a lot of
people will lean on the fact that
they're so busy and they can't take on
any more and they feel like whatever but
I think that's kind of a cop-out way to
look at it you know yeah yeah you're
making those choices you're deciding
priorities and yet okay yeah we just
need to reshift our priorities because I
think I think and this is probably
something that everyone gets into during
like the period of like trying to hustle
and grow is that's like your priority
over everything else but I think you you
can only do that for certain a period of
time yeah you know and ya know burnout I
think that's one of it correlates to
like the viral video thing a lot of
people will shoot for a viral sensation
and then they have this explosion and
then that's the thing and they continue
to chase mm-hmm I personally have never
tried to actively do that because it's
not sustainable I wouldn't be able to
continue that and then I'm setting
myself up for failure yeah I think it's
the same kind of thing when you like
load your set your time up your your
front loading everything and then you're
not gonna have time later on to add more
and it's you know yeah it's the same
thing that's time management in a viral
video it's so funny what I just realized
it's like you were in the chair and
we're on the couch it's like therapy we
don't want to take out too much time
there's a really cool conference going
on out there but thank you so much for
being on our podcast and joining us and
words bye thanks
[Applause]
all right and we're back hello
time-traveling Evan and Caitlin yes all
right so my thing of the week is
obviously this camcorder the quality I'm
looking at it right here
it's it's it is really good I will admit
it and our last one was kind of potato
it was pretty potato like you guys seem
a little out of focus on the podcast
video I was like now we have no more
excuses also I wanted to give a shout
out to a video that was really
instructive to us why while we were
doing this desk build it's is it was
about doing the river table but we'll
link it in the description it was just a
really well produced very like this had
so many tips in it I just wanted to give
them a shout out well you got a look up
who they are
oh okay you do your shout out wide look
so my thing of the week is okay so some
of you guys might know this but I love
jenna Marbles and she recently so does
that my thing of the week so she
recently did a video where she followed
like a five-minute craft tutorial and I
don't know if you guys know who
five-minute crafts those they're like an
infuriatingly
huge like bad life hack channel so
they're just notorious for like posting
life hacks that don't work but they have
so many views in so many followers so
they posted this video about a gene
chair like a chair made out of four
pairs of jeans that were stapled
together and somehow come together to
make this chair and so she tried
following that tutorial and making it
herself and it's just what I love about
it too not only is a good content but I
just love that she knows why she's
making the video she could have sewed it
she could have used the service
she could have actually made it but that
wasn't the point and I love that from a
content creator point of view I mean
it's just I don't know it's just like I
love that she she knows why she's doing
and she's sticking to her guns she only
used a normal office stapler watching
your like an industrial straight all
right but it was like no that's not the
point
it's my boys doing what they do in the
video yes it doesn't work all right so I
looked it up the link will be in the
description but it's from a company
called easy composites limited I think
it is a company that's the company and
then they make a epoxy product and it's
an advertising for the the product I
like the video is just so well done so
well done like super super informative
like if you want to learn all the
details and all the tips about doing any
kind of River table type thing
it was super helpful yeah I'd love this
like we make crazy videos where we mess
around an experiment and learn and grow
and everything and then there's
wonderful people like this that make the
crystal clear tutorial just straight up
tutorial exactly like no nonsense but no
and no it's a time but also very clear
okay was there anything else we were
supposed to do okay this is wrap up okay
okay thank you so much for joining us on
today's podcast if you haven't given
this review would really appreciate it
it helps us grow it helps us
upgrade the equipment even more I'm not
sure what up guys are coming up next but
we want to make good content for you
guys and your support really means a lot
yep so thank you guys oh we also
appreciate a sub on the channel yes to
thank you guys for watching slash listen
as always analyst units week
[Music]